[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
7,8 les invités voici les titres 577 les
indépendants de la droite et du centre
se lance dans la campagne des
législatives le mouvement lancé l'an
dernier et porté par le maire divers
droite de neuilly sur seine jean
christophe fromantin souhaite s'imposer
dans le paysage politique parole à jean
miss le coach du club de rugby de
plaisir après sa victoire sur marcq en
baroeul 31-16 ce week end son équipe
n'est plus qu'à un match de la montée en
fédérale 2 vincent vinel jeunes
musiciens mal voyant de naissance des
clayes-sous-bois tu fait sensation cette
saison dans the boys nous l'avons
rencontré samedi dernier lors d'un
concert au cultura de sa ville de la
politique pour débuter cette émission et
cette vague de renouvellement qui se
poursuit avec notamment 577 les
indépendants de la droite et du centre
un mouvement lancé l'an dernier portée
par le maire divers droite de neuilly
sur seine jean christophe fromantin une
réunion publique était organisée
vendredi dernier à versailles pour
lancer la campagne du candidat dans la
première circonscription des yvelines et
présenter les idées du mouvement
nicolas kirillovitch le titre de cette
réunion publique c'est un appel pour le
renouveau de la droite et du centre
qu'est-ce qu'il faut changer selon vous
puisque vous parlez de renouveau vous
avez forcément une idée de changement
dans la tête qu'est ce qu'il faut
changer selon aujourd'hui pour la droite
et le centre
je crois que la politique elle a besoin
de se renouveler de se régénérer par des
nouveaux profils par des nouveaux
talents par des nouveaux regards sur sur
la vie sur le monde sur les enjeux et
nôtres comment dire notre tendance
politique qu'on qualifie de droite et
centre elle a besoin à la fois je pense
de se renouveler par justement ces
visages mais elle a aussi besoin de se
renouveler par ses idées en ayant des
idées plus réformatrice plus audacieuses
qui s'imprègne davantage aussi tous les
changements et tous les enjeux du monde
d'aujourd'hui
alors la réforme des territoires c'est
votre première idée vous en avez décliné
principalement quand vous voulez réformé
par exemple ces territoires là vous
pensez à quoi concrètement qu'est ce que
vous souhaitez faire par exemple je
pense d'abord que il faut réformer
l'organisation même des territoires qui
est beaucoup trop lourde mais en france
on a nos nos villes nos
intercommunalités nos départements nos
régions nos services de l'état qui vient
de se superposer sur tout ça est donc ça
quelque part ça anesthésie une partie
des initiatives locales
que ce soit pour un entrepreneur ou
comme à vous pour un homme politique
local
il y à une tel à tel contexte de normes
de règlement d'autorisation que tous
ceux qui ont envie de prendre
l'initiative sont souvent très dissuader
de le faire conduite la complexité de
notre système administratif en général
donc on se dit voilà la première chose
c'est de remettre un peu de simplicité
de bon sens de simplification dans tout
ça et ça appelle d'abord une grande
réforme de nos institutions
c'est un peu la langue lé d'apac de
notre projet politique pour revenir sur
le renouvellement de vos candidats vous
allez présenter uniquement des candidats
qui n'ont pas eu de lien on va dire
direct concret avec la politique est ce
que ça veut dire que toute expérience en
politique est mauvaise selon vous non ça
veut dire surtout que on n'est plus
légitime parce qu'on parce ce qu'on a
réussi que par l'étiquette comporte oui
moi je j'ai aucun problème est qu un
maire qui a mené des actions très
concrètes des grands projets dans sa
commune et qui a cette légitimité non
pas de son étiquette politique mais des
projets qu'il ait réussi comme un
entrepreneur est légitime pour la
qualité des l'entreprise qu'il a montée
qu'il est réussi et je pense que il faut
qu'on s'attache davantage ella a pointé
la légitimité de l'action de la réussite
du succès de l'audace plutôt que cette
légitimité des partis politiques qui ont
perdu tout lien de confiance avec les
français
alors votre ambition à la basse et
d'avoir 577 candidats est ce que vous
allez tenir ce pari puisque on arrive
presque au bout de ce qu'on aura un peu
plus d'une centaine de candidats
puisqu'on avait mis ce filtre un petit
peu dur on a demandé à ce que chaque
candidat pour arriver dans notre
dispositif et au moins 100 soutien et un
minimum de promesses de dons pour
justement ne pas avoir
des candidats qui manquent d'intérêt
donc on a reçus à peu près mille 600
demandes de candidature et au filtre de
cette exigence d'avoir au moins sans
soutien beaucoup n'ont pas réussi à
franchir tous les obstacles
mais du coup les candidats qui ont
réussi ce parcours sont des candidats
très déterminé bien implantés et qui
font des campagnes solide et on passe
aux sports et on reçoit jean miss le
coach de l'équipe de rugby de plaisir
sur le plateau son équipe vient de
réaliser un match strass stratosphérique
contre marcq en baroeul les plaisirs
wallon emporté 31 à 16
bonsoir ah oui stratosphérique il
fallait bien que le place belge van
houtte et alors c'est pas une blague
pas évident mais françois comment s'est
déroulé alors ce match vous êtes un
homme heureux
alors heureux satisfait pour la première
manche de cette confrontation avec marc
à marolles satisfait par rapport à la
prestation de l'équipe
voilà repas encore je serai peut-être
certains maîtres et j'espère dimanche à
16h30 ahmar khamr sur leurs terres alors
qu'est ce qui s'est passé durant ce
match c'est vous c'est déjà vous avez
fait une bonne saison vous fait une
bonne saison
là vous êtes surpasser ou c'est le
travail de mon moi là qui a payé
alors c'est une bonne saison c'est le
fruit d'une bonne saison
le fruit aujourd'hui effectivement de
d'un travail collectif avec avec
frédéric jardin qui entreront ce club
fait cette équipe première et il faut
pas oublier aussi l'équipe réserve qui
qui cartonne aussi c'est vrai puisque
l'équipe réserve qui est en quarts de
finale du championnat de france dimanche
prochain
donc c'est tout un groupe de seniors qui
a félicité aujourd'hui à plaisir à la
tête aussi je vais leur dire et je veux
le dire avec florent un but jae lee yann
lacroix et deux entraîneurs la réserve
c'est tout un groupe et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le fruit d'un
travail de tout un groupe senior qui
paye par rapport au résultat pourvois
sur les deux équipes
vous êtes arrivé il ya deux ans l'équipe
descendait là vous vous rapprochez de du
but de votre arrivée dans cette équipe
les faire monter et qui prennent
confiance pour aller le plus loin
possible
vous êtes un match là en fait on rien un
match on est un match il faut pas non
plus se voiler la face on est à un match
et on est quand même favorable quoi ça
c'est sûr faut pas dire non plus croiser
les doigts
on croise les doigts mais il ya quinze
points 15 donc il faut pas non plus
négliger ses 15 points
foppa faut pas faire l'autruche en
disant bon c'est bon on sait régler
points c'est pas arrivé du tout du tout
du tout il faudra vraiment aller là bas
avec beaucoup d'humilité et le même
sérieux même encore plus parce que la
réception sera très très très très
difficile et très compliqué mais par
contre voilà je crois qu'aujourd'hui sur
la continuité sur l'état d'esprit sur la
vie parce que j'en ai beaucoup parlé dix
matches mais on a eu une envie énorme
une envie collective énorme et c'est là
dessus que c'est là dessus que en ce
moment sur les deux dernières
prestations à domicile on est
j'ai pas une véritable mais presque il
yal'envie mais ça ne fait pas tout vous
le préparez comment ce match à
l'extérieur
on vous attend ben oui tout à fait la
vie c'est juste un des facteurs mais on
va continuer à travailler
des deux entraînements d'avant cette
rencontre qui est capital pour nous mais
on va être dans la continuité
franchement aujourd'hui on est plus
d'inventer quelque chose ou ont modifié
on va juste un petit peu regardé et j'ai
déjà regardé la vidéo donc juste un
petit peu faire quelques réglages
travailler un petit peu ce ses réglages
de travail et aussi par rapport à
l'opposition
par rapport à cette équipe qu'on a vu
dimanche dernier travail et peut-être
sur ses faiblesses
pariez sur nos forces et puis essayer de
rendre la copie la plus propre possible
vous n'allez pas me donner la stratégie
c'est sûr mais vous y allez en faisant
un match préparer comme d'habitude ou là
s'est repris en défense terrassement
avoue surtout pas surtout pas c'est une
question non surtout surtout pas je
pense que c'est on le dit souvent un
sport mais c'est surtout pas le la
méthode à adopter adopté parce que faut
pas jouer en disant on va préserver les
15 ou 20 je crois qu'il faut il faut
qu'on y aille
on y va pour faire un résultat pour
gagner et après on fait les comptes il
faut pas regarder il faut pas regarder
le résultat allait il faut y aller en
disant voilà c'est 0-0
et puis on y va pour faire un match on y
va pour gagner dites moi vous gagner le
match
11 ig que vous le gagnez en tout cas on
l'espère où on le perd nos moins de 15 2
points - là et vous montez vous vous
sentez prêt pour cette nouvelle excuse
moi peut-être du mot poule
alors chaque chose en son temps
aujourd'hui on est pour le match de la
montée et l'accession en fédérale 2 pour
la saison prochaine
donc chaque soldat et
ben l'année prochaine si on monte des
j'espère quand même on à café
le boulot à la maison je pense qu'il
faudra poser la question plus au
président voir un petit peu l'objectif
du club après coup savoir ce qu'ils
veulent faire et voir avec qui surtout
ils veulent le faire
merci jean miss mais au courage pour ce
match à toute l'équipe aussi
merci beaucoup il a fait sensation à the
voice lors des auditions à l'aveuglé en
interprétant lose yourself d'eminem
vincent vinel jeunes musiciens mal
voyant de naissance habite aux
clayes-sous-bois il était samedi en
concert au cultura de sa vive
nous en avons profité pour parler de son
aventure dans l'émission
il appelle la petite barbie parce que
c'est une toute petite blonde qui m'a
croisé qui attendait une amie à elle à
la gare et qui est tombé si on m'a
vraiment par hasard et qui m'a branché
sur le projet the voice
au début j'y croyais pas du tout
et en fait au final à une semaine après
leur contact elle me dit bonjour seebach
beat the voice ob d'accord ok donc du
coup et c'est là où on prend conscience
qui se passe quelque chose qui est
quelque chose qui se crée et qui est une
dynamique qui se crée et c'est là où
commence à flipper natrass aussi parce
qu'on se dit bon là on rentre dans la
cour des grands on rigole plus faut
donner le maximum
ça fait super plaisir d'avoir un coup de
projecteur sur soi et en même temps
voilà ça nous permet de nous exprimer de
pouvoir transmettre la passion de la
musique qui est je pense que c'est
important de pouvoir la transmettre avec
un maximum de personnes parce que la
musique c'est fait pour partager je me
suis lancé dans l'aventuré réellement
pour keep de faire de la musique et de
le partager avec un maximum de personnes
et j'entends que j'aime bien qui
vraiment n'inspire bas ça va être me
cahen naturellement florent pagny alors
dans un autre registre michael jackson
freddie mercury voilà ces chanteurs qui
ont de la voix qui donne tout et c'est
un peu ce que je fais comme je peux
mikhail est complètement barré
moi aussi jusque là donc du coup je
trouve que ça que ça marche bien de ce
côté là et puis voilà j'ai une théorie
c'est que si ce monsieur a réussi à me
comprendre en 2 30 en 2 minutes 30
il sait comment de faire travailler
voilà il a compris comment je fonctionne
et ça c'est important
les chanteurs que j'aime bien qui
vraiment m'inspire bas ça va être me
cahen naturellement plan pas ni dans un
autre registre michael jackson freddie
mercury basse et chanteurs qui ont de la
voix et qui donne tout et c'est un peu
ce que je fais comme je peux j'essaie
d'avoir une voix élastique au maximum de
pouvoir avoir des graves des aigus est
passé de
des graves et aigus et aux aigus très
très vite
et ça me permet justement d'être assez
flexible dans ce que je veux faire et ça
me permet de chanter un peu tout et
c'est ça qui est bien c'est la fin de ce
set 8 des invités merci de nous avoir
suivis et bonne soirée
[Musique]